so we're talking about this Union this
marriage between our heart and our
brains a very very different way to
think about things uh in the west very
different from what we are traditionally
invited to consider when I was in school
I was taught that the brain is the
master organ in the body and when I am
working with indigenous people often I'm
taught the heart is the master organ in
the body I want to just say to you that
both of those are valid in some
circumstances but the truth is they're
both incomplete because what we now know
is that while the brain our brain
releases the chemistry into our bodies
for Rejuvenation and healing and
hormonal balance and all these other
things our brain receives many of the
instructions that tell it what to do
from the heart and we are the ones that
create the instructions through our
thoughts feelings emotions beliefs that
we are creating in our hearts because
now as you remember the studies are
showing our heart has ability to think
on its own to remember and to feel on
its own hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I quit I'm a business partner I
struggled to keep going I was making 300
bucks a month and felt like a complete
failure and the thing that saved me that
pulled me up was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs I got the
motivation from them I also got the
strategies of what to do next so that I
can go off and achieve my dreams and
quite honestly I still need the stories
today myself to continue my motivation
to take it to the next level so today
let's learn from Greg Braden Joe
dispenza Bruce Lipton and more enjoy
we're having a new sense of what this
heartbreaking connection is all about as
I mentioned before we've been
conditioned to use them independently
one or the other so I'm acknowledging I
know this is a very different way to
think about our heart and our brain to
think about them as two organs that
support a single common neural network
and just in case there's any question in
your mind that network is about the
nerves it's about the spinal cord
between the heart and the brain and the
vagus nerve between the heart and the
brain and this conversation between the
heart and the Brain it fascinates me
it's a big conversation that's happening
in every moment of every day but the
thing is most of the conversation is in
fact coming from our heart to our brain
that's where the thickest nerve bundle
is to support that conversation there is
a lesser conversation from the brain
through the spinal cord back into the
heart so while it's possible the brain
doesn't say too much the heart the heart
has a lot to say to the brain so we've
explored many of the potentials that
come from Awakening
this marriage this Union between the
heart and the brain and there are others
we're just barely scratching the surface
but what I'd like to do now is share
with you a technique a technique so that
you can tap these Potentials in your
life when you choose to do so
what scientists know is that every
moment of every day as I mentioned
there's this conversation it's a
conversation between the heart and the
Brain the heart is speaking to the brain
and the quality of the conversation that
comes from the heart and the Brain tells
the brain what chemistry to release into
the body
so for example when we're feeling
emotions that we would typically
consider negative and I don't like to
characterize emotions as negative or
positive but I'm doing this so you get a
sense what we're doing here
when we have emotions such as anger hate
jealousy rage
what you're seeing on your screen is an
actual printout of the quality of the
signal from the heart to the brain and
you can see it's very chaotic it's a
very Jagged signal it's a rough signal
and it's that chaotic Jagged rough
signal that signals chaotic chemistry in
your brain this is the kind of chemistry
that tells us that we need high amounts
of adrenaline high amounts of cortisol
the stress hormones to respond to
something quickly in life that's a good
thing for a few moments you don't want
to live your life day in and day out
like this if you can create a feeling in
your heart
of 0.1 Hertz then that feeling is going
to harmonize your heart and your brain
now in indigenous Traditions that I've
been with they have techniques to do
this there are a vast and Myriad number
of applications for the one technique
that we're going to do right now and
this technique is the doorway for all
the potentials that we have just listed
by achieving heart brain coherence it
opens the door and we get to choose it's
like once we're in this place now we can
do this this or this we can do
subconscious we can go into intuition we
can simply use this technique before we
go to bed at night to begin the sleep
and trigger a healing within our bodies
we can do it first thing in the morning
we can do it before our yoga we can do
it before our martial arts we can do it
before our Qigong our healing practice
any of these things because everything
goes better with heart brain coherence
that's all we're doing is we're
optimizing the conversation between the
heart and the Brain between your heart
and your brain so how do we do this
three steps the first step is to Simply
shift your awareness from your mind into
your heart
and what I found is in the western
traditions for many people that's easier
said than done I'll ask people are you
in your heart and they'll say yep I'm in
my heart but what they are really doing
is they're still in their brain thinking
about what it would be like if they're
in their heart this is where the
indigenous Traditions come in
our ancestors told us and when I spend
time with my indigenous friends I say
how do you guys do this
and they say it helps if you can gently
touch your heart center physically in a
way that's comfortable for you and the
Mayan Traditions you see an open Palm
right on the heart and many of the
Middle Eastern Traditions you see the
same thing in the Buddhist Traditions
you see a prayer mudra that physically
touches the sternum
he is any of those things creates a
gentle touch a physical sensation right
over the heart center and your awareness
will always go to the place where you
feel the sensation that's the key so if
you can create a touch over your heart
your awareness will go there first step
Second Step very simple slow your
breathing
a little bit slower than typical maybe
five seconds inhale
five seconds exhale
and here's why that's powerful because
the only time you would ever slow your
breathing and breathe in that way is
when you feel
safe when you feel that you're in a
place that's safe and you're not
threatened and you're not Vigilant of
your surroundings
so you're telling your body you're in a
place that's safe slow your breathing
third step and this is the key
is to begin to feel the feeling
that creates 0.1 Hertz
feel the feeling that sets up the
coherence between your heart and your
brain how do we do that I gave it away
earlier we've already mentioned it
scientists have found at the Institute
of heart math their researchers have
found that there are four key words that
work almost a hundred percent of the
time for everyone
appreciation
for anything or anyone gratitude for
anything or anyone care
and compassion if you can feel one or
some combination of those feelings in
your heart while you're breathing as if
your breath is coming from your heart
touching your heart center now you're
setting up this communication between
the heart and the Brain now you are
triggering those neurons
to begin to reach out and find other
neurons to strengthen this connection
and that's why I mentioned before it
takes about 72 hours three days to build
these networks so that means the more
you do what we're about to do right now
the stronger this connection becomes in
your life rule number two is get Beyond
yourself with Joe dispenza what do you
tell people who struggle with that
assertion of will that that needs to be
there to overcome the addiction to being
yourself right like the you know if
there's someone who just who believes
what you're saying like yeah yeah I get
it but they're still finding themselves
not quite stepping up to the plate to
put that phone down to go through that
meditation the first thing to break the
habit of being themselves but because
they're addicted they just don't have
that will like what do you what do you
say to them I say come to a week-long
we'll take care of you in a week right I
mean we'll take care of you you know I
mean there's so many times the husbands
get dragged to these events with their
wives you know and they're sitting there
like
you know by the third day I'm their best
friend man their hearts wide open
they're I mean they're healed I mean
their crazy stuff happens and and look I
mean
it's a movement now I mean I'm waking up
in my dream I I honestly Aubry
never thought
that I would Witness
what I'm witnessing in this lifetime and
there is a new Consciousness emerging
there's something happening where people
are latching on to their own empowerment
latching on to their own unlimitedness
and it's becoming very contagious so the
person
you know I I used to golf a lot with my
friends and I I used to say to them I
mean I'm a decent golfer but I'd say to
them I'm just not good enough to get
upset just I'm really not but I'm gonna
have a lot of fun and and I'm gonna play
and the more fun I have the better I
play I watch you know you you Duff a
shot and then you start getting angry
and frustrated it's the same thing yeah
that's your game is gonna you're gonna
you're gonna make the same mistake on
the next swing because your emotion is
keeping you in your past so you got to
make a choice to self-regulate or not
and the ones that get right back on that
have ice water in their veins that can
settle down and refocus again yeah those
are the ones that execute really well so
the person who can't get Beyond
themselves it's just a matter of
practicing how many balls do you have to
hit how many punches do you have to
throw how many kicks do you have to
throw till all of a sudden you start
looking forward to doing it and and yeah
I can tell you this because I've been
doing it for a very long time some days
are easier than others but I'm not going
to give up I'm just not I mean if I'm
going to carve out some time
then I'm all in I'm not I'm not going to
shut my cell phone off I'm gonna can
disconnect from it it's all going to be
there when I get back what I'm going to
do is I'm going to make my inner World
more real than my outer world and
step by step I mean you can't get
impatient doing this you can't get
frustrated doing this you can't get
resentful doing this you can't force it
or control it doing it I've seen what
happens in the brain you're going to
make your brain worse so sooner or later
you start figuring out that isn't it and
all of a sudden you start following the
instructions and you start going wow
that was really easy what was I doing up
to this point everything but the formula
you were doing everything else but the
formula doing it your way analytical
mind telling you to quit it's too hard
you'll never get it yeah those are the
exact things that are standing in the
way between you and your future and
every time you become conscious that you
do that and you settle back down that's
a victory every time your body wants to
get up and check an email or check the
cell phone or check get up and get a cup
of coffee and you settle it down you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind every time it wants
to go back to the past and romance some
trauma just to reaffirm some emotional
state and you become conscious of that
and you say where I place my attention
is where I place my energy and I'm
siphoning energy out of the present
moment into the past and you become
conscious of it and return back to the
present moment that's a victory and
every time you start thinking about the
staff meeting at six o'clock or five
o'clock in the afternoon and that's the
known and you stop and you return back
to the present moment you're
disinvesting your attention and energy
out of that future and you're making
room for the unknown in your life and
that's a victory and when your will
gets greater than the program because
most people
lose their free will to programs because
they are they are on that wheel where
they are you could take their yesterday
and lift it up and set it under tomorrow
because they're in the habit of doing
everything in a routine way so then when
they've lose their free will to a
program and their body which is a habit
has become the mind now their bodies
dragging them into a predictable future
and they've lost their free will to a
program and you sit down and your body
is telling I'm going to die in this
meditation I'm going to suffocate this
is going to end and I can't and you just
keep settling it back down every time
you do that it's a victory rule number
three is stop being a victim with Bruce
Lipton you're talking about a lot of
people are victims in the world why do
you think so many people Center their
identity with being a victim and why do
you think they hold on to it so tightly
when they know they could reprogram
their beliefs and start living in
accordance with a harmonious life and
being the Creator and manifester as
opposed to the victim who is powerless
yeah well I think the biggest thing some
people say oh yeah you can change your
life and then they find it's very
difficult it's very hard I go why
because they don't know how to push the
damn record button uh you know and so
many of them are talking to themselves
I'm going to make Bruce you do better
you just do better about this you do
better and I go okay let's stop for a
second who am I asking to do better oh
my subconscious I go oh there's nobody
in there
who are you talking to nobody like oh
that's a big waste of time man because
that's not where change comes from they
don't know how to push that button if
you don't know how to push the button
it's frustrating and it says oh it takes
so it's so much hard work to change it's
not easy it takes time these are belief
systems why because they trying it
doesn't work I know that's because they
didn't know how to push the record
button so most people say yeah I can
change but it's not working they said
think positive and I thought positive
and it didn't work it's not working yeah
no because the idea was you can think
all you want but the problem is while
you're thinking you're actually playing
the negative programs you've been
thinking about being positive is
actually creating the negative problem
because you're not paying attention when
you're thinking about being positive so
there's a whole issue people have a
feeling that they can change but they
have no effort they don't want to get in
the game
because I feel it's you know it's just
too much time it doesn't work and I
tried it and it didn't work and then
they give up and then life just goes on
it's seamless you you don't see it it's
just the way you've been living it ever
since seven years old you've been just
living this program if someone had only
said you know what I'm a victim I've got
too much going on I don't have time to
do these new program things you're
talking about the record button seems
like too much work it's it's exhausting
I've tried and started and stopped so
many times with health money
relationships whatever it might be and
I'm a failure at all these things if you
could only give people a five minute
thing to do every day and you said just
focus on this five minutes a day well
let's just get you to get you started to
get you started well they get they get
you started is this
if you like like the first time that I
really started to be aware that my my
subconscious was controlling me was uh
when I was in my car stopped at a red
light and I realized I was going to be
late and then all of a sudden I started
berating myself well you can't do things
right you're not are you idiot you're
such a union how do you forget these
things it was that moment I said wait
I'm listening to what these words I'm
actually stopping I'm not just saying
the words I'm saying the words but I'm
actually listening I said how many
positive things did I just say zero uh
oh there's a problem right there and I
started to realize we have to stop and
be conscious just long enough to listen
to these things they flow through just
continuously you got to stop and tune in
and say what am I thinking
why because if you start to realize that
most of your thoughts are negative and
this is not good enough that won't work
blah blah blah and I said but that's a
creative voice you're talking about
right there that voice is creating and
everything you just said is now part of
your creation so what if you stopped
what if you just uh said wait that what
I did is I just covered up the clock on
my car so I didn't have to see how late
I was going to be and I got there on the
right time it's like why because I
didn't focus on you know all the steps
between here and the destination I just
said I got to get there well I was there
that's how it worked okay so what can a
person do
I think the first time is just for them
to wake up long enough to hear are you
giving yourself positive vision of a
future are you already canceled the
future with it with negative things that
you can bring up any number of negative
things
it's not going to happen because of X
Phil and X you can put anything in there
it's not going to happen I go until you
understand oh my God I am not thinking a
positive thought in this process
well then I'm not if I'm not thinking
positive thought then I don't want those
other thoughts to manifest and that was
a wake-up call should we is there a
place where we should where negative
thinking is a positive
can't say it because it's a delusion
it's a delusion it's not the reality a
negative thinking besides manifesting it
as a reality
it's only and now you are manifesting
well that was when do you want to stop
manifesting I say when you stop long
enough to correct yourself no I don't
want to think that no let me think
something positive let me show you
something
a while back I would have been what
Loosely called manic depressive I'd be
happy most of the time and then
something would go wrong and then the
next thing would go wrong and I know I
would go in a spiral and then it got
worse and I get down and be totally
depressed you know giving myself
self-talk bad criticism not smart enough
not good enough whatever
and I was uh uh engaged this was like a
repetitive process and you know once it
starts it's like oh here we go you know
there's gonna go and I was in my lab
doing something and it required so much
work to get this done and and then there
was a part where I prepared the
experiment then I'm going to run the
experiment it takes like two hours to
prepare and then I start to run it and
if you mess up a little bit the whole
thing goes
and I so I did it the first time I went
to crap and I was like oh God it's got
to spend two more hours putting it all
back together again way out all this
stuff do everything get it ready
I ruined it the second time third time
really put me off because now I've spent
over six hours of the day repeating
experiments that never worked and I got
real mad at myself and I went into that
you idiot you can't do anything right
and it was cool
I was alone in the room
and I hear a voice just right out in
front of me somewhere right out there in
that voice says don't you have anything
better to do than to listen to this
wow and I for a moment I was stunned
like I'm the only one in the room you
know it was my higher self looking at me
going through this
and saying don't you have anything
better and I laughed that's kind of
funny I said sure I'd rather go see a
movie and there was a newspaper I picked
it up found a movie went to the movie
came out clear no more depression gone
okay
the next time I start to go down I
remembered that don't I have anything
better to do I started to laugh
immediately changed just went and did
something else stopped it was a choice I
could continue going back and forth with
that
or with a choice was do something else
and I did it guess what after a number
of times not too many
I never got depressed again because this
really made a habit
that if I would start in that direction
The Habit was go do something else
and that has been now a valid part of my
whole life I carry nothing forward on
this anymore uh and this was like the
freedom because it said oh my God I used
to get so depressed hearing how bad I
was talking to myself about how bad I
was and now it's like it doesn't exist
anymore also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is understand
your potential with Greg Braden as far
as younger Generations I really think
there are a lot of people who want this
change they want a better world to live
in and believe in but they're often met
with peers who don't see the same that
way or maybe family members that don't
agree can you give them any advice to
maybe continue their empowered way of
thinking so that they don't give up yeah
you know this uh this is the year 2016.
and uh March of this year was my 30th
anniversary of offering this material in
one form or another and and my path has
been to Mary the best science of the
modern world with the understandings of
ancient and Indigenous people it's not
science but it's practical wisdom and
marry those together
uh and I uh I brought a consultant in
for a period of time to follow me to the
different programs because I want to
know who I was speaking to and they
prepared these beautiful hard-bound
reports of charts and graphs and pie
charts of demographics who my audience
was and we were speaking to young people
their parents and their grandparents
three generations were coming the young
people often would come to me and say
this and this is directly to your
question they'd say Greg in this room
with these people everything that you
have just said and everything we're
talking about makes perfect sense when I
go to school nobody thinks this way
and I I understand that because I lived
that in my life as well and what I I've
come to understand and this is what I
can say to young people is every one of
us in our own lives we have to develop
what I call the the spiritual anchor The
Rock The Soul compass and it has nothing
to do with religion when I say the
spiritual anchor it's the spiritual
anchor is when we know who we are in
relationship to ourselves we know who we
are in relationship to the Earth to one
another to our past to our future we
know how we are empowered and what our
potential is and once you know that we
then can live Our Truth
in a world where there other people
support it or not when we depend on
other people for that support that's
where we give our power away and that's
where many of us come from
uh I'll just say to the young people
listening um I come from a very
difficult family background
dysfunctional alcoholic family full of
criticism uh
instilling self-doubt uh in in the young
people I have a younger brother
uh we came from the same family and we
had the same criticisms
um I didn't believe
what my father told me about my
inability in life and my younger brother
he did believe it he embraced much of it
and it's so interesting uh two different
people the same family same background
interpreting the information differently
and I attribute
my ability to uh to to let that
criticism roll off of me in my the
blessing I had very early on I knew who
I was and I understood
uh my place in this world at an early
age not everyone has that but I began
looking at an early age
you know it takes a lot of work
to
explore the potential within every one
of us and there was a very famous author
and prophet in the early in the 20th
century his name is Khalil gabran
and I began reading Khalil Gibran when I
was eight years old
and Khalil Gibran there is one sentence
that has been my sole Compass it has
been with me
I think of it every day I apply it in
every situation every relationship every
job every commitment what he said is
work is love made visible it takes a lot
of work to know who we are in this world
and to demonstrate for ourselves our
potential that is our love made visible
that is US loving ourselves in a way
that empowers us to be in this world in
a healthy a healthy way where we thrive
in the presence of all of the changes so
my invitation for any young people is
love yourself and your love made visible
is you taking the time to understand
your potential and who you really are
the good news is we have that
information now new discoveries new
science indigenous wisdom married
together I think we owe it to ourselves
to bring it all to bear in our lives
today rule number five is develop a
greater sense of Consciousness with Jody
Spencer I remember I worked with a
Siberian Mystic and we did what could
have been like an acting exercise and
she wanted me to go through every
emotion and just select it okay now feel
sad now feel happy now feel surprised
now feel depressed now feel overwhelmed
with joy and I would do it but there was
some part of me that says you can't do
this you can't select your emotions your
emotions are determined by the outside
world and I think I was afraid
to actually admit that I really could do
it because then if I could really do it
well then I had all of this
responsibility to actually do this I had
to take responsibility for everything I
feel I could no longer blame anything
out there in the world for how I was
feeling this was all on me so is that
where you see the the biggest resistance
to doing this work is it the resistance
to accepting that responsibility for
giving yourself for not knowing this
before and not being able to blame
anything or where is the resistance to
just jumping in and giving it a try
um I I um I think my my view about that
has changed a lot in the last uh a
couple years uh when you see a person
who is blind because of a stroke and is
told they'll never heal from that stroke
I mean after two weeks if it doesn't
heal you'll normally have to live with
it and loses her job can't drive uh you
know she's clinically blind
uh I'm not the person
uh that is going to tell her you can
absolutely heal this she has to come to
that understanding on her own
so
people uh
many times when they gather knowledge
and information
the information causes them to become
conscious
of what they are once unconscious to
and when you have a greater level of
Consciousness you see possibilities and
in a sense you're energized by
information you're you're enlightened
you're filled with light in some way and
you see possibilities that you haven't
seen before now
getting beyond the analytical mind
is one of the main purposes of
meditation
and I can tell you that the analytical
mind is always going to talk us out of
possibility because it is fascinated on
trying to predict what's going to happen
next
so if you can predict your future
then you're laying unknown on an unknown
and this is a habit we have because the
brain is an anticipation machine
so there's many different
obstacles and resistance resistances
that come with a persistent disbelief
that has been programmed
over and over again I mean I don't watch
television but I've watched it because
of what's happening in the world and I
am so insulted by television commercials
I I can't believe people would sit there
and allow that information to program
them some drug to make them feel a
certain way some look somewhatever you
don't think that has profound effects on
programming a person into limitation
when I wrote the book you are the
placebo
I was so angry at myself for two weeks I
was so
frustrated with myself because I bought
the program
people
believe they the people believe they
need a flu shot
because they don't believe their bodies
in the body's innate capacity to heal
four days
teaching people how to elevate their
state
increased immunoglobulin a in our
research by 50
immunoglobulonate is your body's primary
defense against bacteria and viruses
it's better than the flu shot it's
better than a flu shot
but that's not the information that
people get so there's a layer of
programming that's happening and the
beauty behind all of this is nobody's
buying information any longer I love it
and I'm I'm not prone to believe that
guy in that tube telling me the way it
is and nobody should
and more and more people then as they
start to wake up to information there's
a change in energy
because change in Consciousness requires
a change in energy and now a greater
energy causes systems that were once
stable to become unstable to become
chaotic and chaos is just unpredictable
order it's novelty it's newness it's an
unraveling of systems so hang on this is
a really profound time because it's got
a break
and when it breaks something better come
out of it it's not going to be
governments and politicians and and
religious figures and whatever
leading the way there is no one leader
everybody's got a lead just like those
birds that move in One Direction or
those fish that are all in a school and
they're moving together give the
appearance of something bigger to
Predators you study that principle in
biology
called emergence you think that there's
one leader that everybody's following
everybody's leading
and there's a stigma we have in our
minds that if you lead with too much
passion in your life
you're going to lose your life whether
you're Martin Luther King or William
Wallace or Joan of Arc or
Abraham Lincoln
you're gonna get it and that stigma is
branded in people's minds for a reason
but this is a time in history to not die
for the truth this is time in history to
live for the truth and if you're working
on your anger and frustration and I'm
working on my fear and anxiety and my
judgment and I'm taking care of me
and you emerge in that heart of yours
and I emerge in that heart we are going
to be like-minded we're going to be
connected by that invisible field
now everybody's leading and you just
can't take out everybody now so we can't
we can't wait for anybody else to take
care of us and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is study your brain with Bruce lived in
I really want to focus on something
called an urban myth and this particular
Urban myth is the belief that we only
operate off of 10 of our brain so we've
all heard that yes we're only using 10
of our brain boy if we could use all the
rest of it we'd be super smart but hey
that's all we use firstly where did that
number come from 10 a long time ago when
putting the body together through an
understanding of histology and the cells
that make up organs a study of the brain
revealed one very important fact and
that is only 10 of the brain was made up
of neurons ninety percent of the cells
in the brain were not neurons but they
were called supporting or connective
tissue and given the name glial cells
well what's really interesting about
that is in the neuron principle the the
neuron Doctrine it was believed that the
neurons were the functional cells of the
brain and the glial cells were more or
less just support well then by
definition right away it says then
you're only using 10 of your brain
because that's all the the neurons
comprise in the brain ten percent for a
long time the glial cells again were
thought to be just like connective
tissue support physically and
nutritionally the neurons
but over the last number of decades what
we started to find is this there was a
misunderstanding about glial cells that
glial cells are a lot more important in
neural function than just physical
support glial cells can inhibit or
activate neurons glial cells connect to
neurons glial cells can control the
activity of neurons so all of a sudden
these glial cells which were looked at
as just passive cells in the brain
turn out to be actually quite functional
integrating the nature of how the brain
works and a way of looking at it in a
simple analogy consider that the neurons
are nouns in a sentence and that the
glial cells are the verbs and the
adjectives and the adverbs the modifiers
of all the nouns so the glial cells
create a a fulfillment of a picture so
neurons are like a stick figure and when
you add the glial cells you fill out the
nature of the whole human so glial cells
become a very functional integrated part
of all neuronal activity so the concept
of the neuron doctrine that said only
neurons are involved with functioning in
the nervous system it turns out the
glial cells are as well so now we're not
dealing with 10 percent of the brain
we're dealing with a hundred percent of
the brain yes you have access to a
hundred percent of your brain all of the
time
but does that mean that we actually use
the whole brain all of the time and the
answer is no because what we start to
find out is when we start to live in
patterns and in habits that what happens
is we just activate certain neuronal
Pathways that are habitual Pathways and
as a result these are the pathways that
have preference in our everyday life but
if you can engage whole brain activity
you can enhance your Consciousness and
your awareness and your ability to
control your life so basically it says
that we can become whole brain when we
start to think holistically instead of
just playing recurrent programs that
play over and over again and activate
the same pathways so the relevance is
that once we start to engage in whole
brain activity we enhance our ability as
humans on this planet and now we're
beginning to find out there are many
different ways to engage and activate
the whole brain some of them involve
simple exercises such as something
called brain gym and brain gym is a very
interesting exercise of the body and the
nervous system integration in this way
my right hand is controlled by my left
hemisphere my left hand is controlled by
my right hemisphere but here's an
interesting story if my right hand
controlled by my left hemisphere crosses
the midline
then it simultaneously gets picked up by
the other hemisphere because now it's in
that territory as well so when you cross
your arms and when you cross your legs
what you're doing is causing the right
and the left hemispheres to work
together in harmony
when we are activating brain uh
synchronization we're right and left
hemispheres are engaged together
simultaneously it activates something
like super learning with both
hemispheres working together we have
much more Superior characteristics of
neural function however after age seven
and eight
we start to express what is called brain
dominance meaning during the day we
don't have synchronization of both
hemispheres during the day it's like a
wave form sometimes we're more in the
left hemisphere sometimes we're more in
the right then it comes back to the left
and back to the right so that we're
cycling through one hemisphere at a time
this is called brain dominance where one
hemisphere is dominant over the other
hemisphere well the relevance about that
is integrating Our Lives is very
difficult in brain dominance for a
simple reason has been suggested our
left hemisphere is based on logic and
details our right hemisphere is actually
associated with emotions and wholeness
and this becomes very important because
if you're only looking with your left
hemisphere then all the logic things
make sense but there's no emotional
component to it and reverse if you're in
the right hemisphere you get emotionally
tied up but the logic drops out well
this happens to us ever since the time
we were eight through our adult life if
you can get both hemispheres to be in
sync hemisink then you're engaging logic
and emotions at the same time that opens
up a window for super learning
opportunities where you can download
information very very quickly and very
fast but it also opens up a whole wide
range of thinking that includes an
emotional component as well as an
intellectual component which is
necessary to fulfill a whole picture so
if you're operating from brain dominance
you're actually shutting off one
component of your nervous system at that
time so if you do an exercise like brain
gym where you're involved with crossing
your arms and your legs when you do that
you start to integrate both very
interestingly when we have Hemi sink
we're much more calm collected and able
to really Express neurological functions
that are very fully supporting of
ourselves
and this is why it's very interesting
when you go home and relax at night
sometimes you find yourself with your
ankles crossed over each other just
sitting in your chair without even
knowing what you're doing by crossing
your ankles you're actually engaging a
whole brain process so if you're
stressed for example during the day or
you just want to relax when you go home
at night crossing your arms and legs
actually engages both hemispheres which
calms the system down but engages the
whole brain process so you become much
more effective in your relaxed state so
if you're having a tough moment during
the day just take a moment and cross
your arms and legs hold them together
and just wait for about three or four
minutes and you'll start to feel a
calmness overcome and in this calmness
your neurological functions will be
totally enhanced when we start to
operate from patterns that are replayed
every day we start to express very
specific Pathways that are reused over
and over and over again and as a result
we actually shut down a large amount of
functioning of the brain and just go
through the Habit the patterns that
replay themselves over and over again
so basically what you really have to
understand is this we can use 100 of the
brain but if we play the same patterns
over and over again we don't need to use
100 of the brain so
um simple point I'd just like to suggest
that once you start to recognize that
you can have Hemi sink where you can get
right and left hemispheres to engage
together and stay conscious you are
using 100 of your brain activity and
when you do that you'll also find that
your life is easier more harmonious and
healthier because when you're using your
full nervous system it will support your
life and enhance your growth and this
becomes important so don't get stuck
that I'm only using 10 percent of my
brain that story is false you can use a
hundred percent and it's available to us
and basically all you have to understand
is this stay conscious stay Mindful and
stop playing the same patterns over and
over again because that opens up an
opportunity to create new behavior when
you stop playing the programs
I want to explain something to you that
not many people really understand I want
to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now I want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a why
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type thing the Paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm in the thinking control the
vibration you're in and the vibration
you're in is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
took me nine and a half years to figure
out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here just give
yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
and less that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so this the bottom line
is that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glassblowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zeigon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by whenever somebody would say
Vermont I'd think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to last like
you're out collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're gonna go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was I literally
turned to him and said it's okay dude
like it'd be weird if we're still here
after 10 years I'm gonna track this
thing down I actually said to him you
know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this man my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid I should have bought
a crib or stools but for whatever reason
the zeigon arc effect takes over and I'm
like the painting so I call the mill and
I get this guy on the phone I'm like uh
you know I want to buy a kale Shepherd
piece and I said could you send me
Polaroids and he's like sure and I tell
him the budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you there is extraordinary
science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want you need to create an
environment of Excellence Excellence
most people's environments are not
excellent the people around you the the
videos that you watch the things that
are on your wall the voices that are in
your head you have these moments that
are bold that are courageous that make
you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really matters so figure out how you
love to learn for me it's videos I like
to see things I need to be visual if
that's you then you need to have a way
to have those videos coming into your
life every day it can be part of your
morning routine that's why I make this
channel part of your morning routine
subscribe to the channel every morning
every weekday we got a new video out
there for you to give you the shot of
espresso to help you but if it's not my
channel it's some other channel one of
my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or this the one
video because that one video on repeat
is going to lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you like an
author go find their other books or go
find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him so
be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like Elon Musk maybe you like
Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or whoever
but the more you're around that person
the more you will start to think like
them so you want to put that as part of
your daily routine that every day
because yesterday was a different day
you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today's a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you go to the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when write all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this and I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so
this office inspires me this office this
was all with intent the people on the
wall behind me we got Steve Jobs AP
giannini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be so whether
that's a mood board you put up for
yourself where there's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team
I I don't see my team physically that
often most people work from home I could
just show up every day in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
you want to adopt that or not is up to
you but but how you present yourself for
yourself not just for the camera I'm not
putting this on just for the camera I'm
putting this on because it's what I put
on this is for me
I could make a video of my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
you start to create an environment of
Excellence guys your environment is
keeping you where you are your
environment is keeping you stuck and if
you don't want to be stuck anymore if
you want to change your circumstances if
you don't want to be in the same spot
you are right now one year from today
you have to create an environment of
Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
your entire life will change learning to
create our minds the way we want is the
basis of creating the world the way we
want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate is indeed
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
it's long walk
felt little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested
I wish I had something
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
ask questions
came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you were monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey one
thing about a monkey is it's a necessary
moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of some yukti
he is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body your mind your
emotion and the fundamental life
energies are organized in One Direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
with her simple-minded Faith Works only
for those people who are simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works a
childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all how
you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible
he's destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for a deeper dive into
Consciousness and awareness check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I have people say
something soon to me all the time you
know I don't have time to understand
myself because I'm trying to put food in
my table and feed my family or I'm
trying to do my best in school and I
understand all of that here's the thing
we